below the thunders of the upper deep in
the abysmal see his ancient dreamless
uninvaded sleep the Crandon sleepeth
that's right it's time to release the
Kraken this is the legendary sea monster
it's massive terrifying and hungry
thankfully it's just a myth right what
if this behemoth of the sea actually
existed
how would this Leviathan live in the
real world and how would this monster
affect our lives this is what if and
here's what would happen if the Kraken
were real it's time to dive in word
getting up close and personal with the
mythical cephalopod feared by ocean
dwellers and land lovers alike the
Kraken how exactly would the Kraken live
in our world first we would categorize
the Kraken as a cephalopod like the
octopus squid and cuttlefish the Kraken
would be a highly advanced in
intelligent marine animal cephalopods
are soft bodied so they have no bones to
become fossils that would explain why we
haven't found any remains of a Kraken
but it also proposes a terrifying
possibility if the Kraken lived by the
laws of science it wouldn't be immortal
which means there's more than one and
they're breeding baby Krakens as to
where this is happening we assumed it
would remain in the North Atlantic Ocean
that being said the species of giant
squids alive today inhabit all of the
world's oceans so we shouldn't consider
ourselves to be safe yet your first hint
that you may be in the presence of a
Kraken is that you catch lots of fish
and I mean a lot of fish if it seems too
good to be true that's because it is the
Kraken is scaring the fish towards the
surface and that's a harbinger of death
for unwary sailors giant squids hunt by
keeping still in deep waters when a fish
gets close enough to the dangling
tentacles it's pulled into the squids
grasp and is unable to escape the
suction cups that line the tentacles we
can assume that the Kraken hunts in a
similar style but fish isn't on its menu
it wants you
your crew and your ship the Kraken is
described in folklore as being the size
of a few small islands and its back was
1500 meters in circumference it's also
said that the Kraken was able to pull
massive ships completely underwater with
its tentacles how strong would it have
to be to pull this off
well our committee's principle states
that the buoyant force of an object
submerged in a fluid equals the weight
of the fluid that the object displaces
if you take the gross tonnage of your
ship and multiply it by the density of
seawater and gravity then subtract the
weight of your ship it will give you the
force that the Kraken needs to use to
pull your ship under the water for the
Kraken to pull a regular sized ship
completely underwater it would need to
exert a force of just over 400 thousand
kilograms in non mathematical terms the
Kraken is very very strong and you well
I'm sorry to break this to you but your
Kraken food it's safe to say that if at
least one of these monsters dwelled
beneath the ocean anything involving sea
travel would have happened very very
differently how would it affect us well
if this monster of the deep is lurking
in the Atlantic it would have changed
history as we know it the Vikings
wouldn't have been able to sail over
seas if this sea monster was eating them
come to think of it Christopher Columbus
and his crew may have ended up in a
watery grave and never made it to the
New World in fact North America might
not have been discovered at all until
the invention of air travel now we could
assume that explorers evaded the Kraken
on their voyage but with the Kraken
being such a massive creature it would
need a lot of food to sustain itself
meaning it doesn't look good for anyone
who likes to go in the water
thankfully the Kraken isn't currently
devastating the ocean today
if it ever existed in the first place it
would have been gone long before humans
made their debut the myths and legends
attributed to the Kraken are more than
likely encounters with their very real
and arguably very terrifying giant squid
cousins but after all that we can't
write the old Kraken off for sure
human beings have only searched 5% of
the oceans everything else down there is
a mystery it may be a creature of myth
but we can't imagine it would be fun to
be eaten by a Kraken what if another
real nautical creature decided to make
you its dinner what if you were
swallowed by a whale well that sounds
like a story for another what if